welcome to comic-con Marvel's the gifted
cast your first comic-con
first of all how's it going to talk are
you ready for next year to be seeing
people dressed up as your characters yes
my look already and like bad other
clothes like messy one is lots of people
in Republican suits we've got to talk
about the fact that this is a part of
the x-men universe which first of all is
such a beloved Marvel comic does that
put any pressure on you guys entering
into such an iconic beloved world it
doesn't it doesn't it's a privilege to
be part of that universe at the same
time we have our own you know they're
very it's sort of we don't have to fill
any shoes we're doing we're going down
our own route along the same done iron
route within this universe so it's
there's a pressure of being part of it
or to do it justice and beyond honor it
but other than that why am i bumbling so
much obviously I'm terrified Louis if we
found those shoes would be happy to fit
them
is a dangerous thing built-in audience
yeah like it's it's up to us to do it we
will with it positive or negative but I
mean it's amazing to come into this with
such a strong fan base before we've even
put anything out yeah and I think it's
amazing I mean at least for me I love
the comics but didn't grow up I was like
a super fan like like many of our cast
members so actually I've actually taken
many notes from fans we guide me to blow
the clouds play my character and our
shower mat next heat we you know we're
paying homage to the original mythology
without sticking to it definitely but
just like Sonics you know they if it's
like regeneration or the Exile you know
they take the liberty of like doing
their own story within the realm our own
parts and draw characters and there's
also that thematic of you know people
getting their powers through something
traumatic happened happening to them
which is you know it's great because it
kind of champions the disenfranchised in
society Marvel is definitely having a
moment right now in TV there are so many
amazing shows right now what do you
think it is about the gifted that's
gonna set you guys apart from the other
awesome shows out there as well well the
first difference is like we're not often
like save the world we're just trying to
survive that's you know and it's more of
like the pollutant we've you know we are
certainly our show reflects like the
political climate currently yes why are
you trying to save the city we don't Don
soups and run around or build suits and
have billions of dollars to spend a big
weapon yes it's just really a show about
a family on the run it really is and and
you know we sort of end up in this
subterranean culture which is you know
completely underground running from from
him and who represents everything bad
yeah um for the fans out there who maybe
aren't familiar with
this subsection of the x-men world how
would you describe the gifted to them
we're gonna go down the line and you
guys are all gonna describe what the
gifted is about and finish each other
subjects okay great ready Jamie so our
world is set oh no sorry let me start
over
you know our Marvel Universe takes place
in a time where the x-men and the
Brotherhood no longer exist Amy and
mutants are being persecuted they're
outcasts and a prosecutor of said
mutants who takes them out of the world
basically ends up in a situation where
he's his and teenagers like my character
and Percy's character extremely afraid
to be who they actually are so we're
taken into this this family joins
together bonds together with another
family of a different kind it's made by
Marvel which is awesome and the family
has a collision course with these
mutants who end up having to help each
other
[Applause]
we played it like this Amy and Steven
you both our parents yourselves are you
tapping really into your own parental
instincts from your guiding these two
through there kind of changing this is
like going through puberty on steroids
[Laughter]
like my student to be teenage children
are having with my mutant children is
they're like we don't know how
superpowers mom pesky mutant kids my my
teeth I've got two older teenagers as
well as my two four-year-olds and my two
teenagers are exactly the same age as
these two and so one of them sitting
over there and look like so it's it's
been really interesting because you know
the great thing about what Marvel does
what what model does with this show with
the x-men show is about is about you
know teenagers going through what the
teenagers teenagers go through but you
know set through the prism of you know
being able to fight back against the
things that may be persecuting them or
or difficult in school you know they
when the gene kicks in and it can they
become mutants they're able to fight
back for the first time and so which is
a really nice idea you know for kids who
are going through difficult times and of
course even we have to talk about the
fact that your lovely wife is also in
the x-men universe when you first found
out about this project and you brought
it to her she like go for it
what was her reaction actually I read it
and I really liked it and but she's such
a sort of she's a she's brilliant with
notes and she's brilliant with with
character stuff and so I gave it to and
said please read it and you know as you
probably know because the Internet these
days I had an exploding link so there
was a I'd had two hours to read the
script before the scripts disappeared
and then and then so I got the exploding
link to put
again so that anak could read it and and
she thought it was excellent and and
just absolutely said go for it I can
kiss kiss the chances that we could get
a little cameo a little cross x-men you
know I'll keep getting asked that I have
no power and situation and I don't know
whether it could happen but I but I I
don't think it would certainly not gonna
happen in the near future if it could
happen and and that is not me saying it
is gonna happen I'm just like I don't
know it's part of the same universe
i I am so TV there is no plans for it
what did that okay
okay is it possible I guess so well and
then just a shift ever so slightly you
the true birth family most recently lost
milk and Ellis how are you guys doing
right now you guys are so close together
and as a cast Anna is at the funeral at
this exact second in Chicago with a
bunch of our gang and yes rates off to a
month but you and Deborah are here
together so she's really yeah yeah we
talked about but I'm so excited for the
gifted what is the one thing that you
want future fans to know about the show
before they tune in you can actually say
yeah I'd say just if you want something
that you won't see in any of the barbel
films watch our show it's very much like
a street level view of the everyday
lives of these people there first and
foremost people secondarily